also müssen sagen alex kompliment dass
sich wirklich selbst übertroffen an der
stelle
wir machen das dann wird es wirklich
besser war wöchentlich mit den paketen
und ich etwas genauer und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video ich hoffe
natürlich geht es weiterhin gut auch
wenn wir uns jetzt schon wieder ein
bisschen länger nicht gesehen haben aber
es wird heute sehr nice und zwar habe
ich eine idee gehabt wo man also
letztlich erzählt euch erstmal die idee
und zwar ist mir irgendwie mal
eingefallen wie während das wenn ich
einfach immer freunde von mir ich hab ja
auch ganz viele freunde die ich auf
youtube machen die ihnen zu machen die
man irgendwie vielleicht kennt aus dem
social media bereich ich suche mir immer
wie ein neues haus und was zudem so ein
richtig geiles paket zusammen mit sachen
die der braucht wo ich weiß okay das
sind so seine hobbys seine interessen
mit sachen die da vielleicht nicht auch
mit irgendeinem schrott mit geilen
sachen niveaulosen sachen was auch immer
also das ist wirklich unterhaltsam und
lustig wird und wir starten heute mit
sebastian und max krankhafter und escape
kennen ja wahrscheinlich relativ viele
von euch und ich habe mir gedacht so für
die erste folge werden zwei gleichzeitig
ein schirm geilsten ihr könnt super
gerne weitere ideen oder eure vorschläge
eure wünsche bei dem ich das als
nächstes machen soll
wenig als nächstes ein
individualisiertes paket zukommen lassen
soll in die kommentare schreiben
ich war auch schon fett einkaufen ich
würde sagen ich nehme euch mal kurz
hiermit also viele besorgung habe ich
schon gemacht hier unten haben wir schon
das paket da sind ganz ganz viele sachen
drin
die werde ich euch gleich mal so
halbwegs vorstellen als ich will jetzt
nicht zu viel verraten weil der sinn der
sache ist dass sebastian max dich
hinsetzen das paket zusammen auspacken
mir dann dieses video schicken und dich
darauf dann noch mal so ein bisschen
reagieren also okay dann startet man mal
eben auf alle sachen kommt dann noch so
eine kleine notiz von mir drauf das
mache ich noch nachträglich das zeige
ich euch nicht damit die wissen für den
was ist und was ich mir auch vielleicht
dabei gedacht haben wir starten erst mit
dem paket für beide zusammen das ist
jetzt erst am 18
egal also wenn ihr jetzt unter 18 seid
und ist es halt so kauft euch das halt
nicht nach also das soll jetzt keine
werbung dafür seien aber ich weiß oder
ich war als zuschauer in köln geboren
doch wir waren sehr sehr auch
zusammenschließen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht kaufe ich
den beiden doch meine neues eine neue
sharp ein ganzes set wir haben wir alles
dabei alles was man sich nur vorstellen
kann
und da werden die sich hoffentlich sehr
freuen dann habe ich für sebastian der
ist fitness typ habe ich hier mal ganz
ausgefallenes whey protein kauft und
zwar cookies and queen ich glaube das
hat er noch nie probiert vielleicht mag
es hier haben wir was für max und zwar
wachs kocht sehr gerne vielleicht könnt
ihr das format einen tag persönlich
getroffen da dachte ich mir mache ich
mit sonder 40 nichts falsch und rein was
sagt mir dass das doch eine kleine
stürze oder damit kocht man noch besser
es sind auch viel mehr sachen dem
vergeht das will ich euch jetzt mal noch
nicht zeigen damit die überraschung auch
für euch später noch besser ist wenn ihr
halt das paket aus cotton und ich darauf
reagieren wir wollen das erstellte post
und dann sehen wir uns wieder so weit
da bin ich idiot jetzt habe ich die
karte vergessen ich habe extra noch eine
karte gemacht nein ich habe hier nämlich
noch diese wunderschöne karte design ich
habe mir einmal sebastian hier machen
hier haben wir das paket und hinten habe
ich noch eine kleine große nachricht
draufgeschrieben damit auch alle
bescheid wissen für wen was ist aber wie
kann man denn so blöd sein jetzt muss
ich ja wieder zur post gehen oder moment
mal vielleicht auch nicht hat das trifft
sich ja gut ich zeige euch noch mal und
zwar wollte die chance nutzen um euch
die post und dhl app mal zu zeigen und
ein bisschen näher zu bringen und vor
allem auf zwei features die jetzt neu
sind sehr sehr nice da kann auf jeden
fall safe jeder was mit anfangen der ab
und zu mal briefe verschickt so wie ich
das jetzt halt auch vorab und das ist
super entspannt erst mal kann ich
wirklich jedem nur nahelegen sich
einfach die post und dhl app aus dem
appstore oder place to runterzuladen das
geht ganz schnell
und wir schauen uns immer ein wenn ihr
ein paket erwartet oder weg geschickt
habt könnt ihr hier über ganz einfach
auch die sendungsnummer eingeben
ansonsten kann man sich natürlich auch
ein konto erstellen und hier anmelden
das muss man aber gar nicht ich möchte
euch heute nämlich einfach mal die
mobile briefmarke das ist jetzt neu
erklären wie das ganze funktioniert und
euch auch die vorteile davon einmal kurz
auf zeigen dazu gehen die aktionen
einfach mal
auch versenden und müsse man hier den
brief aus bilden also aktuell gilt das
nur für briefe und postkarten sendungen
dann wählen wir einen standardbrief aus
bis zu 23,5 x 12,5 x 0,5 cm
das ist das vermag wo ich die karte
eingesteckt habe wählen das aus kostet
80 cent jetzt habe ich mein paypal damit
verknüpft habe hier meine e-mail
eingegeben ab so hier unten muss ich
noch einmal die agb bestätigen dann
wähle ich hier aus als code zu
beschriften so zeigt bezahlen das dann
eben mit paypal geht ganz schnell
dann haben wir es den korb porto 69 y
krm sie benennt und dann ist praktisch
mein gerät im umlauf also ich kann
einfach den kordon draufschreiben jetzt
hier zu hause mit dem stück von mir den
dann so abschicken und das war schon so
das habe ich jetzt alles erledigt und
dann hoffe ich kommt meine karte auch
noch passend zu dem paket an aber da bin
ich sehr optimistisch ich sag ihnen
eigentlich auch die sollen vorher das
paket öffnen bevor die die karte nicht
haben so leute da sind wir auch schon
ich freue mich mega die briefsendung ist
sehr schön angekommen das paket ist auch
angekommen und das werden die beiden
jetzt zusammen aufmachen
ich hoffe sie freuen sich und wir
schauen jetzt direkt mal rein viel spaß
dabei ich bin auch sehr gespannt auch so
für die dds ich kenne das ist sebastian
wurde er max jetzt ist weiß ich dann
auch mal die ganze geschichte jetzt mal
aufhört als allererstes dem brief hier
wären dazu bekommen
mit hinweisen zu sehen was da ist
übrigens hinter der kamera ist max
gleich hallo reine pakete aufmachen
können hallo die da drin sind
danach haben wir die karten
das war ja ganz ganz wichtig dass sie
auch lustig ist ich wunder mich jetzt
gerade die wo ist denn die andere seite
fragt sollte ich finde die platzierung
von mir finde ich nicht so korrekt nicht
noch mal überlegen ob ich damit mache
ich mir was du lieber max ein weinpaket
mit vielen leckereien und produkten mit
der hoffentlich was anfangen können oder
vielleicht auch nicht damit klar ist für
revassist arbeitszeiten beschrieben als
kleines genau die leute mega entspannt
einfach im briefumschlag gepackt die
mobile briefmarke drauf das ging recht
schnell warum nicht nur das ist auf
jeden fall etwas sehr nice mobile
briefmarken kann ich jedem von euch nur
empfehlen
und jetzt freue ich mich auf das paket
wie machen wir das ja zu nimmst du erst
mal deine sachen
dennoch scheint man auch meinen sachen
alex doppelseitiges klebeband verwendet
weil er für die sicherheit der danach
auch doppelt und dass somit nicht so ok
das war immer so dass man nicht wie also
ich freue mich auch sehr jetzt hier
sehen zu können
und ja das für dich ich glaube auch
steht dass sich auch max für die
maximierung hat der max falsch
geschrieben die haben mag ich das ding
ist für alex zuschauer ich bin da
relativ krass ja also auch relativ
muskulös und so und deshalb ist das
wahrscheinlich für mich korrekt
was haben wir cookies cream ja ja ist
als das ehre als stichwort chips drehte
er hat das in der protein jia und auch
eingewandert ich dachte erst es ist ein
projekt fließen auch für dich auch schon
also ich kann mich viel zeit also alex
ist sehr lieb von dir aber ich finde es
scheiße dass du mich so auf ja mein
dasein als bodybuilder reduziert weil
ich habe auch noch ein bisschen mehr
facetten in meiner persönlichkeit krass
ich dachte das ist so voll sein ding
richtigkeit das steht hier
okay das ist nicht nur ein wenn das sind
ja prinz hat ja zu genau allerdings
sogar dass eine schüchterne ja das ist
richtig stabiler euro dass da viel
rascher aus und wir haben hier nicht nur
eine shisha wir haben ein ganzes paket
da ist alles bei den ab heute noch
darüber nachgedacht
sie sagte ich rauche niescier deswegen
habe ich auch keine shisha da und
logischerweise noch kein schüler mit
einer kaputten baulich erneuern wollte
also dass der sebastiani darauf würde
ich jetzt so nicht unterschreiben
insofern passt das richtig gut können
mir aber bitte warum oman air ist dass
sogar die die wir hatten
omv peters kommen ja auch den kampf oder
war das eine die wir mal als kinder
hatten
nein des kommentars kinder folgen ja
weil das was ich meine die die als
kinder hatten somit 89 jahren hat man ja
kriegt man ja normalerweise seine erste
shisha von den eltern und dann kann man
sich auch irgendwann mal eine eigene
kaufen darüber so achten sie beim kika
ja dass ich krank die ja das ist dass
ich dachte ich okay überhaupt auf wird
schon etwas lustiges drin sein
das ist gemeint wenn die zu schaffen wir
haben hier ein rattenproblem wollen wir
das beste gelebte mit bio
ich habe das gerade gar nicht gesehen
hinter der kamera kann aber durch sehr
nice ich glaube ich würde also wegen der
platz komponente wirklich bereit
erkenntnis zu mir zu nehmen
ich habe mir hat jetzt gerade ihm schon
noch platz frei gemacht extra wäre es
nicht schlimm so leute jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt jetzt macht max weiter weil für
max war natürlich auch einiges dabei ich
sehe gerade was das würde das
schubladendenken nur perfektionieren
denn jetzt für dich hier bier drin wäre
mir alkoholfreies bier das er persönlich
auch für dich wegen sport werden
ausschnitte
ich habe mir nämlich gedacht das ist
bier hier bei uns aus der region und
alkoholfrei weil ich dachte ich hab ja
schon wieder eingepackt das ist schade
ja schon genug der gesundheit wir wollen
sie auch nicht übertreiben deswegen
natürlich von mir nur alkohol und wenn
ich dann nochmal einmal kurz
unterbrechen darf das ist jetzt auch das
letzte mal ich bin letztens dann doch
mal bei der post gewesen weil ich noch
ein paket weg bringen musste und eine
sache und der würde ich euch super gerne
noch erzählen und zwar ist dass die
briefmarke mit matrix code eine sehr
geile sache wie ich finde so sieht das
ganze aus ich bin es euch sonst hier
auch nochmal ein und zwar konnte man das
jetzt ja briefe und postkarten sendung
nicht schrecken diese briefwaage macht
es jetzt möglich da ist über diese
matrix code drauf megageil das wollte
ich euch noch kurz zeigen jetzt gehts
weiter
damit ihr haben damit ihr nicht damit
ihr nicht immer kölsch trinken
ok diese größe von 18 euro bei gott
dafür mit wein noch besser schmeckt das
ist ein fakt der sich die
zufälligerweise in der intimsphäre
diese batterie bilder wirklich nicht
dass sie da war das sieht aber nicht so
gesund
wir können die machen
ich würde ja gut dass man darauf einigen
können ausgefallener tabak für bei aber
ist der haushalt von der kabeg ja das
ist für die stadt und die masse habe ich
vergessen wir haben hier noch der mast
sie aber wirklich den großen teil des
flusses und profit mehr proteine für
mich jetzt der ganze bus dienstag für
die schwache nicht anders sieht das auch
nicht machen
damit neues auto auch immer schön sauber
bleibt so
jetzt sieht man dass ich glaube das ist
jetzt mal ohne witz ohne witz da sind
wirklich viele sachen dabei wo ich im
letzten tagen gedacht dass wir die holen
will
zu zweifelhafter handstaubsauger
brauchen auch der gewisse ich habe
keinen kleinen bisher so kann man
dorthin könnte wahrscheinlich
den kann man in jedem auto kann man den
laden du kannst ihn überladen und das
gute ist das ist mein eigenes produkt
bald erhältlich oder ist schon
erhältlich aber ich dafür glaube ich
keinen punkt ab das ist also wirklich
das sind einige sachen ich dachte ich
bin alles gedacht ist wenn er uns in
drin aber es sind wirklich und mit
sebastian okay jetzt hier irgendwie das
ist die störungen
ich glaube es liegt am magnetfeld damit
der job das ist für mich damit lager die
noch lieber beim kochen zusieht
aber hey es ist verstehe ich jetzt nicht
weil ich sehe auch ohne die stürze schon
so auch nicht schlechter abend von
solltest du dich hässlicher machen
ich möchte dass das ist man dieser mann
erscheint einer küche was macht ja also
sehr aufmerksam und das wollte ich mich
tatsächlich schon länger war ich habe so
ein bisschen wunschliste
es brauche aber das ist jetzt natürlich
aber das bett der übrigens hätte wenn
ihr wissen wollt was ihr macht wenn
dieser mann nicht erscheinen von
experten beschreiben haben ja ich kann
einfach weiter eco ist ja nicht auch
haben und hier das ist glaube ich ein
bisschen video ironisch webers grill
bibel falls du es schon hast so habe ich
tatsächlich noch nicht und ich liebe
grill durch passen zu dem wetter diesmal
leute megageil das ist habe ich extra
für maxi kopf da freuen wir jetzt ja
dass er das noch nicht hat weil ich
dachte der zeigt was der isst hat ein
kocht er kocht viel und das ist die
weber grill bibel dann stehen ganz viele
rezepte denn nur das beste hat wie viele
seiten sind das mittel also müssen sagen
alex kompliment sich wirklich selbst
übertroffen an der stelle
wir machen das dann wird es wenn ich
sage besser aber wöchentlich mit den
paketen und dann sehen wir ja das freut
mich auf jeden fall mega dass die beiden
sich so gefreut haben eure aufgabe ist
es jetzt weitere influenza youtuber was
weiß ich irgendwelche personen des
öffentlichen lebens stil feiert die cool
findet in die kommentare zu schreiben
wenn ich noch ein paket stecken soll
da möchte auf jeden fall machen wir
sehen uns nichts wenn man schon im
zweiten paar dieses formats wieder
abonnieren superagent den kanal danke
anwachsen sebastian die verlinkt auch in
der video beschreibung und ja haut rein